Beauty And The Beast director Bill Condon
did a great job adapting Disney's classic
animation into a live-action movie, but during
the editing process some intriguing moments
got cut including some funny battle scenes
in the castle and a very different take on
the song "Days In The Sun".
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and with the Blu-ray of Beauty And The Beast
out, I'm going to break down all the official
deleted scenes and discuss the many easter
eggs and call-backs to the original animated
movie as well as other details we never got
to see in the theatrical release.
I'm also starting a new giveaway on this video.
For a chance to win this gorgeous hardback
book "Tale as Old as Time: The Art And Making
of Beauty And The Beast", just subscribe,
leave a comment about the movie, and make
sure you also answer the question I'll be
asking later in the video.
By the way, obviously there are spoilers ahead
if you haven't seen the movie!
During the battle between the enchanted objects
and the villagers at the Beast's castle, there's
a funny little moment that was cut with the
Village Lasses.
The scene shows the Lasses, armed with pitchforks,
chasing Chip and FrouFrou, through the castle
and into the kitchen.
Which is where Cuisinier, the castle's chef-turned-stove,
covers them in treacle and feathers, and they
run off screaming.
This scene is actually a lovely call-back
to the original animated movie where LeFou
and two other men with assorted weaponry race
after the castle's enchanted footstool, who's
stolen one of LeFou's shoes, until they're
threatened away by the kitchen's fiery stove.
Also deleted from the battle at the castle
is a scene where Lumiere is attacked by one
of the female villagers, and Cogsworth comes
to his friend's rescue, sliding down the bannister,
and shooting the villager in the butt.
However, when she turns round, Cogsworth is
shocked to find that the person he's shot
is Clothilde.
Now, if you remember, at the end of the film
when the enchanted objects turn back into
human servants, we discover that Clothilde
is actually Cogsworth's wife, and that he's
definitely not happy to be reunited with her!
Which explains why, in this deleted scene,
Cogsworth continues to fight her off with
a sword even after he knows who she is!
Again, this deleted scene is a delightful
throwback to the original animation, where
Cogsworth saves Lumiere from being melted
by LeFou.
In that animated scene, Cogsworth choses between
a pistol and a pair of scissors, and comes
barrelling down the bannister, stabbing LeFou
in the butt with the scissors, using them
like a sword.
In the final live-action film, Plumette strikes
LeFou in the face with her feathers, but we
don't see what happens to her next.
The section that was cut from the movie after
that shows LeFou rushing after Plumette and
catching her in a net.
However, Lumiere comes to her rescue when
he uses his candles to burn LeFou's butt.
In the animated classic, it's not LeFou but
one of the other villagers who's mistreating
the enchanted duster by plucking out her feathers,
but again, Lumiere saves the day by torching
the villager's behind!
During the mob scene at the castle, LeFou
continues to question his allegiance to Gaston,
and in a humorous deleted scene, he hides
away from the fighting in one of the castle's
many rooms.
Unfortunately for LeFou, the room he picks
is an enchanted bathroom where a new character
called Monsieur Toilette drenches him with
water, which sends LeFou rushing off screaming.
Then at the end of the film, when the household
objects transform back into human beings,
there's another deleted scene where actor
Stephen Merchant appears playing Monsieur
Toilette just standing there, clothes wet
and dirty, mouth agape, basically completely
horrified by what he's been through during
the curse.
When LeFou arrives he identifies Monsieur
Toilette due to the terrible odour, and asks
him what he's going to do now.
To which Toilette replies: brush my teeth!
And if you're wondering why all these little
moments I've been talking about so far were
cut from the end movie, it was really a question
of timing and taste, as according to director
Bill Condon the movie was running long and
some of the humour was considered a bit low-brow
in comparison to the rest of the film.
There are some lyrics missing from the Mob
Song in the live-action film compared to the
animated movie.
The missing section would have fit into the
film just after Gaston consults the Beast's
magic mirror to check where the castle is,
and it features the villagers making their
way through the woods, while singing the lines:
"We don't like what we don't understand.
In fact, it scares us.
And this monster is mysterious at least.
Bring your guns bring your knives.
Take your children and your wives.
We'll save our village and our lives.
We'll kill the beast."
Then straight after those words, the deleted
scene shows the villagers breaking down the
ice gates that lead up to the castle.
This shot of the villagers storming through
the broken gates is beautiful and kind of
symbolic as it looks like they're walking
through the jaws of a beast.
I can see why Bill Condon was sad to cut the
scene, though he did so as he was aware of
the film's running time and also felt it downplayed
the tension of the moment.
A scene that was cut from the movie's opening
section shows Belle giving the beggar woman
Agathe some bread and jam, which she's very
grateful for.
It's just a small moment between these two
characters, who we don't see interact during
the final film, and it highlights Belle's
kind and compassionate nature, and also emphasises
how different she is from the other villagers
who treat Agathe unkindly like an outsider.
And, on top of that, this deleted scene may
also go some way to answering the question
of what happened to the baguette that Belle
bought from the baker, which was in her dress
pocket during the opening song one minute
but mysteriously disappeared the next!
It would have been nice to see a bit more
of Agathe in the movie because her character
is rather important, after all, she is the
Enchantress in disguise.
And if you'd like to learn all about the secrets
of the Enchantress in this movie, then check
out my video on that very subject by tapping
in the top right of the screen.
After the townspeople throw Belle's soaking
wet clothes all over the ground because they
don't like her new laundry cleaning invention,
there's a scene that was cut from the film
which shows Gaston arriving, blasting his
gun for the crowd to make way and telling
them they're behaving badly and should go
home.
While this may seem, on the surface, like
a decent thing to do, as usual, Gaston has
his own best interests at heart, and those
interests involve convincing Belle to marry
him so that he can have what he believes he
deserves: the best wife in town.
It's always fun watching Luke Evans play the
incredibly arrogant but ultimately clueless
Gaston, and I love the line he says to LeFou
after he tells the crowd to leave,
"I'm not sure what's going on here, but I'm
pretty sure I just fixed it";
however, I can see why this scene was cut
as it doesn't add anything new or revelatory
to what we learn at the start of the movie
about the characters of Belle and Gaston and
their attitude and feelings towards one another.
The musical number "Days In The Sun" was a
new song introduced in the live-action movie,
however, there is an alternate version of
the song which begins with the Beast dreaming
of his mother singing to him when he was lying
in bed as a young boy.
In this alternate version, the prince's mother
sings the first part of the song, saying that
she'll never leave him until her own life
is done.
Now, the middle of this deleted version is
the same as in the final film, but at the
end of the cut version, the prince's mother
has died in her bed and her young son watches
over her until he's pulled away by his father.
This original version had to be partly reshot
after it was discovered that test audiences
were mixing up actress Harriet Jones, who
plays the prince's mother, with Hattie Morahan
who plays Agathe, aka the Enchantress.
Because of this confusion, the scene was changed
with Harriet Jones's role cut back to a non-singing
part where she just lay dead in her bed while
the prince looked on.
And in the re-filmed scene, she also had dark,
rather than blond, hair to further differentiate
her from the character of the Enchantress.
Also, the young prince's part was recast with
a young actor who could sing as he now had
to sing the first few lines of the song as
it appears the final film.
It's a shame the original version wasn't used
as actress Harriet Jones has such a lovely
singing voice and that version packs an even
stronger emotional punch because the prince's
mother sings to him that she'll never leave
him, but by the end of the song, she's dead
and he's asking why she left him.
Plus, the alternate version gives at least
one real moment on screen for the prince's
mother, whereas her time on screen in the
final film was reduced to almost nothing.
I feel like instead of altering this scene,
they could have simply re-filmed it as it
was but changing the colour of the mother's
hair to make the difference from the Enchantress
even clearer.
So, what do you think about the deleted scenes
and where there any you think should have
been in the movie?
And which animated Disney film are you most
looking forward to seeing made into a live-action
movie next?
To enter the giveaway for this gorgeous hardback
book "Tale as Old as Time: The Art And Making
of Beauty And The Beast", make sure you're
a subscriber, leave a comment about the movie,
and also answer the following question: "what
two things does Belle give Agathe in the deleted
scene?"
Now, remember to turn on your notifications
to see all my new Beauty And The Beast videos
and to find out if you win the giveaway.
And if you enjoyed this video, don't forget
to give it a thumbs-up and you can also check
out more of my Disney videos below!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.